[Applause]
yes yes
hello everybody
hello everybody it's Friday and you know
what that means
tomorrow's Saturday
let's welcome tonight's guest she has
more experience reporting on Sports than
cat does complaining about them oh
Southern Michelle Tafoya podcast
Michelle Tafoya
pop
he wants CRT to rip senior fellow at the
Manhattan Institute Christopher RuPaul
she's like a UFO mysterious nocturnal
and often found by Farmers Fox News
contributor
and finally he can cap raise 12
holsteins
it's a cow it's a cow everybody my man's
inside kick in the NWA World Heavyweight
Champion tyrant
I gotta make fun of uh Joe Mackey all
right before we get to some new stories
it's Friday so let's do this
Greg's leftovers
hmm yeah it's leftovers where I read the
jokes we didn't use this week and as
always it's my first time reading these
so if they suck we're gonna push Joe
Mackey off a cruise ship
you know they never arrest anybody for
that hardly encourage it all right here
we go drink some water
cool
this week a nude woman was arrested
after she fired gunshots on a California
highway she's being charged with three
counts of impersonating Hunter Biden
that's a good one
Hunter's plea deal with his own father's
justice department blew up this week
this after prosecutors refused to give
back the property Hunter had left at the
White House
yeah meanwhile the White House ruled out
the notion that President Biden would
pardon his son it's the most trustworthy
Biden promise since Hunter told London
Roberts he'd pull out
what what what are you talking about
legal analysts are afraid Hunter will
walk or Worse Joe will try to walk
it's got four minutes are pretty good
the IRS has announced it will no longer
make unannounced visits to most homes
and businesses especially this one
officials revealed this week that a
Florida Manatee died after having too
much high intensity sex with his brother
yeah aquarium officials say the animal
sustained a 14 centimeter rip in his
colon
and then attributed the death to covet
who knew that about manatees maybe
that's why they smile so much
in Sacramento two shoplifters were
caught on camera blatantly stealing from
a local business police say the suspects
are on the lamb
and on the pork chicken beef and fish
suspects are described as armed and
gelatinous
the Miss Italy beauty pageant says they
won't allow competitors who are
biological males organizers say it's the
only way to stop contestants from
pinching their own asses
that's because you know in Italy that's
what they do they say I wouldn't know
the new first dog Commander has been
accused of biting White House staff
Commander released a statement saying oh
he can sniff but I can't bite
[Applause]
case is director for the White House
said it could be a unique and often
stressful environment for pets
especially for dogs who spend time near
the Presidents since they can't tell if
staffers were picking up his or theirs
oh
disgusting the hottest new fashion trend
sweeping Beijing is the face keaney a
full face mask made from UV dis
resistant fabric I can think of one
place where face kidneys should be
mandatory
a woman who threw her 36g bra at the
rapper Drake at his recent concert
received an offer from Playboy and her
bras received an offer to cover the
infield at Yankee Stadium
the Venice Film Festival refusing to
rescind invitations to disgrace
directors Roman Polanski Polanski and
Woody Allen but they apologize for
scheduling their appearances during the
children's matinee
like you're offended
[Laughter]
you've already forgotten the joke in
celebration of national muster day who
knew
Skittles will partner with French's to
make its first ever mustard flavored
candy
yeah parent company Mars says it will
feel his welcome in your mouth as a
loaded handgun
that's funny
shooting in your mouth a just stop oil
protest that illegally blocked traffic
in the UK caused a pregnant woman to
crash her car earning the group praise
from Planned Parenthood
[Laughter]
sad yeah 77 year old Cher is launching
her own line of gelato
laughs
stop there
all right I'll go further
unlike Cher though it won't contain any
chemical preservatives
terrible
you people you people make me sick
finally new maple flavored spam will hit
stores shelves this fall in a related
story bright stelter dislocated his
right shoulder doing backflips
some news
and cause wokeness killed their brand
and employees bear the brunt of Bud's
woke marketing stunt so Bud light's
parent company Anheuser-Busch is laying
off about 380 employees in corporate and
marketing roles Brewery and Warehouse
staff however aren't affected their
punishment to keep making Bud Light
Financial experts say these layoffs are
a clear push to shift away from
Progressive Politics as no one wants to
watch woke political agendas shove down
their throats and more importantly they
need the empty offices to store all the
beer no one wants to buy
of course it's the latest Fallout
stemming from the Dylan Mulvaney debacle
you remember the self-proclaimed girl a
trans influencer celebrating the joys of
Bud Light she had all the feminine wiles
of a young Don Knotts
portraying a beer drinking bubble head
in a bubble bath Dylan didn't just ape a
woman she played them as ditzy morons
I'm surprised she didn't heat that
bubble bath by tossing in a toaster oh
God and while workers get the boot
Dylan's getting the loot as we mentioned
last night Dylan could earn as much as
40 Grand a speech on an upcoming
college-speaking tour
get this Dylan's teaching women about
female empowerment which is like cat
teaching men about the bench press
but is it really empowerment when a
lucrative female speaking gig goes to
Dylan who knows maybe Mulvaney's the
right man for the job
whoa I misgendered I meant person
Michelle I hate it when I do that I hate
it when you do that all right is it fair
that they fire all those people I mean
it seems clear to me that uh beer
shouldn't really need a marketing
department well they certainly didn't
need Alyssa heinershide I think is her
name who was the decision maker behind
that whole thing I kind of worry about
her like she knows all of this is a
trickle-down effect from that single
decision that yeah you know what I mean
like I wonder what she's doing and how
many phone calls she's making to
apologize to people I kind of concerned
but look you don't need that much
marketing for a a beer but if they had
fired the lower level people it would
have looked awful right they had to fire
the upper level people and look they've
lost a ton of money yeah Modelo is now
the number one beer it's more expensive
so it's not selling the same volume but
is it Modelo owned by Anheuser-Busch I
don't is that great I feel like it is
yeah I think it is so it's like they
just shifted all the money over the
there they now need to find a trans
Mexican
Modelo Mexican
I have an idea
where's that dude from Menudo
Ricky Martin there we go God
all right Chris congratulations on this
book America's Cultural Revolution by
Chris Ruffo you're a you're you're the
spear the tip of the spear in this war
against crazy woke culture what do you
think do you think that your companies
are starting to learn the lesson they
absolutely are I mean for many decades
companies had everything they needed
from the cultural and political right
they had tax cuts deregulation they
spent 2020 pandering to the furthest
elements of the radical left on BLM on
gender and all these ideologies and only
when these companies feel the pain on
the other side did they change their
behavior these corporations are amoral
they operate on a system of incentives
so conservatives finally after so many
years proved that we can shift
incentives and decision making we should
feel no hesitation obviously we feel bad
for the individuals who lost their jobs
you have to hang tough because Bud Light
is not just a corporation that aired
it's a symbol and it's a warning for
every other Corporation keep the
politics out of my beer out of my
regular products and then you'll have
what you need from the political right
yeah and you know what keep politics out
of politics
that's what I say
cat this must upset you I mean basically
Dylan Mulvaney stole a 40 Grand a gig
job from you you could be doing female
empowerment at various college campuses
but instead Dylan Mulvaney is and he she
whatever does not have a percentage of
talent that you have
I think that was a compliment
thank you you're welcome uh I don't
think it was just Dylan Mulvaney that
created these issues for Bud Light I
think it was also the outright admission
that they were intending to turn off
their huge customer base by saying it's
the brand is out of touch it's fratty
and we need it to be inclusive to you
know for women and men
that to me is saying that women can't be
fratty which I take offense to right
because I'm a very fratty woman you are
I'm in your office yes you've also seen
me play cornhole I'm very good
and where did I learn that a frause
I was never in a fraud I was the first
lady of one for a while no very good um
and so better than the last it's true I
think oh what what'd you say
I don't even know what that means no
what did you say I said better than the
last
I
don't know if I get it no I think you do
I don't know I think you should get it
all right
a sexist would say or just you would say
to me every day
access I think you're just mean to me
the phrase Woman face yeah because
that's what it is Woman face yeah
we're not black cat because you were
making a point please I was making a
point but I'm glad that was yeah please
excuse the little guy go ahead
because I I am so tired of talking about
you were the worst at the job ever yes
sir you were horrible people lost jobs
because of you and the genius who was
out of touch talking about who's out of
touch because the one thing I hate to
hear is when I hear the word Corporation
and I hear groups blacks whites it's
individuals who have this God complex to
think they know the pulse of the people
with no experience wisdom or character
and when they look around and make
decisions America said no and instead of
that you know what she's not calling
people absolutely not because that's the
it's the people it's the toxic men's
fault it's the system they it's the
system that came after them the evil
Republicans came after him but here's
this where were the people that you
supposedly were representing how come
when you switch Bud Light to Awful
bubble bath scenes with people with no
rhythm where
where did what was that you know like
you try so hard because you're so fake
but where was the group to buy up all
the Bud Light where was this massive
unrepresented group that's suffering
that jumped in line just like Dave
Chappelle when he was protested there
was eight people there and they still
have the mitigated Gall to have a
megaphone yeah
it's true it's true I think that you
know people say it's greedy to say
prophets come first but if you make the
profits first it's for the customer's
benefit if you start having a parallel a
parallel I don't know aim which in this
case would be diversity or I don't know
whatever or climate activism you take it
away from the the main principle aim
which is a prophet which you can only
make if you make a good product and
please your customers which is what we
do here at Gutfeld Incorporated
take take the company tour
we do a uh
we do a gut Build Incorporated company
tour every third Thursday of a month
that begins with the letter M so you
have to sign up on sign up outside and
then leave 400 deposit hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else